the netherlands is a small country
it's so small you could fit it into the
u.s 270 times
but it's big when it comes to making
food
remarkably it has the second largest
agricultural
exports in the world mainly through
being able to produce
vast amounts of food on tiny plots
here's how the dutch
learnt to feed the world
[Music]
the netherlands isn't exactly designed
for mass farming because of limited
space
farmers have learned to eke out as much
as possible from the land
with a third of the country under sea
level the dutch mastered how to make
land using levees
and built windmills to drain marshland
to create fertile soil
this area just outside of amsterdam
flevopolder is the largest artificial
island in the world
and didn't exist half a century ago
nowadays
over half the ground in the netherlands
is used for agriculture
it makes more food than its people can
eat but there was a time
when the dutch faced starvation
1944 and the allies begin to liberate
europe
the nazis occupy the netherlands and
begin a blockade of the north
it created a food shortage so severe the
dutch government encouraged its people
to forage for acorns and chestnuts
tens of thousands perished from famine
after the war as the dutch rebuilt
ensuring food security became a priority
the issue was important to the new
minister for agriculture siko manshold
a former farmer and a resistance fighter
in the war
he'd begin to drive changes that would
turn farming into big business
before the war dutch farms operated like
those in most other countries
small plots had a few livestock and
produced a mixture of seasonal crops to
service local populations
mans holt wanted mass production and
built on a decades-long system of state
support for farming
he pursued a policy of land
consolidation larger more productive
farms were encouraged to absorb smaller
less profitable farms
it was all about using less labor to
improve yields
in 1963 the government launched a fund
to help older farmers sell up and to
help young farmers start new businesses
state funding into research and
technology such as fertilizers and
machinery followed
and thanks to aid from the u.s marshall
plan numbers of tractors rose quickly
helping farmers work more land dairy
production grew fast as cooling tanks
and milking machines were invented
in 1960 the average dutch dairy cow
would produce
4200 kilograms of milk per year
in 2007 this had nearly doubled to 7
880 kilograms oversupply of milk wasn't
a problem
the dairy board created joris tripinto
and he encouraged kids to drink plenty
of it
the technical innovation didn't stop
with machines
the dutch pioneered specialist
greenhouses creating conditions that
would result in many more plantings than
ever before these greenhouses are in the
southwestern section of the netherlands
and they enable farmers to grow crops
the year round
with temperature and humidity carefully
controlled an elaborate water system
keeps the crops properly moist
if you were to put all of the dutch
greenhouses together today
they'd cover an area the size of
manhattan
farming under glass another example of
dutch ingenuity
then a huge discovery in 1959
the vast groningen gas field would offer
greenhouse horticulture a huge boost
farmers profited from the cheap energy
as their crops benefited from the heat
and the added co2
the netherlands now has the world's
highest yields per hectare for cucumbers
chili peppers and tomatoes all carefully
picked for their profitability
reducing water use is part of making
efficiencies too
today some farms use just four liters to
grow a kilo of glass house tomatoes
the global average is 214 leases
all this built on a rich culture of
farming that already existed
the dutch were master breeders of plants
and livestock
and were a nation of traders thanks to
the ports of rotterdam and amsterdam
the state built on this expertise to
transform farming
including a focus on education and
research as part of a holistic approach
to benefiting the entire industry
[Music]
it hasn't all been good though the dutch
have been criticized for getting ahead
with over-intensive methods
and using synthetic fertilizers to boost
production
they're now working to change this in
1999
the country used more fertilizer than
any other european country
spreading on average 500 kilos per
hectare
by 2014 though that figured more than
halved
by working together farmers scientists
businesses and the state turned the
netherlands into a world leader in
modern farming
its knowledge and state-of-the-art
technology will be vital in tackling the
future of a rising global population
with billions more mouths to feed
you